Вірмени розлючені. Вони вважають капітуляцією підписання угоди з Азербайджаном і Росією про припинення вогню.
Згідно з нею, Азербайджан отримує контроль у низці районів. Натомість у регіон приходять російські миротворці.
Після таких домовленостей обурений натовп у Єревані захопив будівлі уряду та парламенту.
Протестувальники побили спікера парламенту, розбили двері та вікна.
Прем’єр Вірменії Нікол Пашинян у Фейсбуці намагався вгамувати громадян. Текст угоди щодо Карабаху він назвав болючим для країни.
Усі ті, хто розносять зараз парламент, всаджують ножі в спини наших солдатів, які перебувають у траншеях.
Один політик зажадав моєї відставки, а днем ​​раніше залишив позиції в місті Шуша.
Але дії декого з тих, хто увірвалися в будівлю уряду, можна зрозуміти.
Вони родичі загиблих солдатів, і я схиляюся перед ними.
Пашиняна підтримав лідер невизнаної Нагірно-Карабахської республіки,
який теж спробував пояснити, чому було ухвалено саме таке рішення.
Якби бойові дії тривали такими темпами, ми втратили б весь Карабах і було б значно більше жертв.
Я хочу попросити своїх дорогих співвітчизників протверезіти:
громадянська війна, нетерпимість - все це велика загроза для нашої країни, не тільки для миру в Карабасі, але і для миру у Вірменії.
Давайте об'єднаємося і обдумаємо все, перш ніж ухвалювати будь-які рішення.
Тим часом, Росія вже активно перекидає своїх миротворців у Нагірний Карабах.
Загалом у регіон мають прибути близько двох тисяч російських військових.
Вони перебуватимуть на лінії розмежування в Нагірному Карабаху щонайменше п'ять років.
Угода може бути подовжена за згодою сторін. За словами німецьких експертів, ці домовленості вкрай вигідні Росії.
Відправляючи миротворчі сили у Нагірний Карабах, Росія отримує постійну військову присутність у регіоні.
Ми всі пам'ятаємо про те, що конфлікт у Нагірному Карабасі був єдиним
так званим "замороженим конфліктом" на пострадянському просторі, де не дислокувалися російські війська. Тепер вони там є.
Ще один важливий аспект, на який вказують у Німеччині, - це створення коридору між Західним Азербайджаном і Нахічеванню,
який повинен контролюватися прикордонною службою ФСБ.
Завдяки такому контролю Росія посилює свій вплив в Азербайджані, а також і в Туреччині.
Створення цього коридору - величезне досягнення і для Анкари.
З турецької точки зору, цей коридор уможливлює географічне з'єднання турків і азербайджанців,
тобто встановлює прямий наземний зв'язок між Туреччиною та Азербайджаном.
Однак цей коридор буде перебувати під контролем й управлінням Росії.
Нині багато експертів обговорюють, в якому форматі та на яких умовах будуть присутні турецькі військові в Карабаху.
За словами аналітиків, і в Анкарі, і в Баку намагаються представити ситуацію так, що Туреччина виступає з Росією в регіоні на рівних.
Туреччина спільно з Росією візьме участь у роботі миротворчого контингенту,
який буде розміщено в регіоні для спостереження за виконанням угод.
Ми підписали документ щодо розміщення турецько-російського центру з контролю за режимом припинення вогню.
Під час нашої розмови з моїм дорогим братом, президентом Туреччини,
ми обмінялися думками з приводу роботи турецько-російського центру з контролю за режимом припинення вогню.
Я думаю, це дуже важливий крок. Це новий формат кооперації в регіоні,
коли Туреччина і Росія відіграватимуть рівноправну роль у вірмено-азербайджанському конфлікті.
Однак німецькі експерти не бачать у подібній кооперації повноцінного альянсу між Росією і Туреччиною.
В Анкари, на думку оглядачів, позиції в регіоні слабші, ніж у Москви.
Це разове партнерство на підставі спільних інтересів. Але не варто його прирівнювати
до створення повноцінного альянсу. Туреччина не є стороною в угоді про припинення вогню.
Туреччина дуже б хотіла ввести в регіон власних миротворців, але Росія проти цього.
Втім, деякі експерти вважають, що досягнення Росії - лише тактичного характеру.
Пожертвувати довелось стратегічними інтересами Росії, переконаний, зокрема, оглядач Іван Преображенський.
По-перше, за підсумками війни Москва втрачає такого вірного союзника як Вірменія.
Ефект може бути подібний до українського або білоруського.
По-друге, тепер на мапі з'являється нова точка, де можуть гинути російські солдати.
По-третє, відбувається закріплення на Кавказі історичного супротивника Росії - Туреччини: Ердоган піде, а вплив залишиться.